so you have this app that you can see
the local fires around you and this week
there have been many many fires in
portugal and this is actually us right
here and all around us are wildfires
kind of scary so we figured let's have a
look at one of those
welcome to a new project camp update
[Music]
hey you might have seen it in the news
many heat waves and wildfires in europe
in every cafe or bar you go here you see
fire on the news and the government
stands out as a mess with fire alerts it
feels like portugal is on fire so we
figured since they're so close by let's
get in the car and see one
ferrari
i guess in the middle of nowhere but we
just found like a sign of a fire in the
horizon when we crossed by the highway
so we stopped and now we try to find it
over this bumpy road
we're currently 10 minutes away from a
big fire
we're not sure what we're gonna see
smells like something
so there's the fire looks quite
impressive actually helicopters around
it giving water
village close by
but yeah it feels like a lot of smoke
coming in this direction
kind of want to see it a bit closer
so here you see the fire and the amount
of people there 60 12 vehicles and two
helicopters or planes
you can see it's scaling up like more
people coming more vehicles
so it's still very much a growing fire
all right
wow it smells good
[Music]
my god
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're running
over there in the back is a big fire
that's kind of scary actually
like that
you hear some people i think they're
putting the water on it
and there's raining ash here the whole
village is
empty some people in panic some people
are
crushing their floors i don't know why
but uh yeah weird atmosphere helicopters
going
very strange
there's someone up there as well yeah
so the farmer firefighter looks more
like a farmer
so they're currently 90 firefighters 21
vehicles
two aerial we actually recently sell a
plane with water and two helicopters
actually century
so it's planes and helicopters right
yeah
it feels like we should help or
like that farmer guy [ __ ]
you guys are you standing there now
[Applause]
unless you're paying for the firefighter
that you feel you get it under control
and
it's smoking this is moving
oh that's how you spread the fire i
guess
wow
so we were just at the fire it was
impressive but then while we were at the
fire we saw another fire occurred 40
minutes away so we're now going there
i think it's even as double double the
amount of firefighters there
so let's see
so
apparently we found it huh
looks like we found it i hope otherwise
it means there's another bigger
[Music]
so we're now in another place which we
found over the app
we just jumped over a fence because the
road was blocked
and now you see there some beautiful
spinning windmills
with some smoke and some fire
yeah there it is
so here's the second fire we found a
easier way just drive on top with a car
a lot of people are watching it
but uh quite intense there are three
times as much firefighters as in the
other one way more airplanes going
around with water
but there's less tree it's more like all
these bushes on the ground but it's
really a massive surface that is just
burning and growing
as you can see here now
so
it's impressive the size of it
windmills still to go
so they're selling the field on fire
right now
and then it burns i guess and the fire
cannot continue
[Music]
so we live on a piece of land close by
and forest fire will be one of our main
risks living here and they also seem to
be increasing here and around the world
but we realized we actually don't know
too much about them so we made this
special fire episode to find out
so after seeing fire we wanted to know
more about how do they start are they
increasing and are they even bad
so we drop by at the local fire station
to understand more about it
so we are here today at the firefighters
place it's just the municipality that
involves our land as well and today we
will have an interview with the chief of
the firefighters and he will explain a
bit more how fires work and
how firefighters also work and we might
get a tour around the establishment and
all the equipment that the guys have out
there so let's go
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
um
um
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
um
statistics
[Music]
see
the
okay
okay
like
now we've seen the fires and talk with
the firefighters next we want to have a
look at a recently burned land to see
what it looks like afterwards
so
[Music]
so we're currently at a burned down land
burned down a few days ago
as you can see it's still a bit burning
there in the back
everything on the floor is like ash
still warmies as well
and they actually say in the recent days
40 000 hectares burned down in portugal
which is four times four thousand times
as big as our own land it's a lot
and fifty three percent of that was
forest area so a lot of trees burned
down
yeah i guess this is what it looks like
this isn't even fully burned there's
still some trees there in the background
they might survive maybe not
but yeah besides that it's all burnt
still smoking there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so here you have a stone building still
standing you actually see it in this
landscape that the stone structures are
still standing the rest burns down
and i think it actually influences
people's choices a lot around here how
they build things
using stone or concrete buildings don't
use wooden window frames or plastic but
use metal or aluminum
think also for us is going to be quite
an important factor for our land in the
future like what kind of building
materials do you use and
are they fire resistant
a lot more to figure out but i can now
understand a bit why you would do
inside the little ruin
wood is still there
survived
house for wasps now
nest
burns
and seeing this you really see the
effect it has on the environment and how
it changes the landscape and people
choices
but we still don't really understand
what to do are fires natural is it a bad
thing and why are there so many
especially here where it rains so much
and how would you avoid this in the
future so next we're gonna have an
interview with a professor who's been
analyzing fires for about 30 years it
will probably be a bit lengthy but i'm
sure it will contain much valuable
information
my name is joaquin
sandy silva
i'm a professor at the college of
agriculture so in portuguese
school of superior grades
and i'm teaching basically
topics related with um with forest fires
probably
that what makes
uh
portugal such a
fire-prone country
is the human factors so humans that put
fires and humans that should put out
fires
and we are failing in this part so uh
people are basically the the big cause
of force files in portugal i know that
this this is controversial because not
everybody agrees with this but
from
what i see and what i've read
um
i think we we have two
too much ignitions
and uh and
and uh
a firefighting
organization
that it's not suited
to
at least not enough
to this fire regime that we have
so um and then we have another
problem which is a big one
that is uh exotic plants
like uh eucalyptus and acacias and uh
akia which is a spanish road that is
increasing um in central portugal and
northern portugal
and these species
they are very well adapted to fire so
when fire comes they spread they
regenerate they reproduce and so the
area of eucalyptus is growing
also thanks to forest fires
the area of acacia is growing very much
because of forest fires even worse um
apparently we are creating a fight cycle
because
the more these species
spread in the landscape
the more the the landscape becomes
becomes fire prone so you have a cycle
of invasion
and burning
and more invasion
so in many regions in portugal the the
the
normal fire regime is that it burns
every
10 years or 15 years or 20 years which
is not enough for the the vegetation to
become uh more mature and and for trees
to go to grow
so you you have this central region of
portugal which has a very high fire
hazard and also the northern
part of portugal
um and then when you go to the south
although the climate is much harsher so
it's it's much more
hot during the summer and dry so
apparently
one would say well why doesn't it burn
that much in the south because you have
a limiting factor which is the fuel so
you don't have enough fuel there to make
big fires uh
occur also you don't have
that much ignitions because it's much
less populated so you don't have
so many people
doing activities that cause fire
well that
that's a very
that's a big issue even and it's not
consensual even among the scientific
community you know what i can give you
is my perspective
um
no
we we have to to put it in historical
terms because
and and also geographical terms because
um it's not the same when you talk about
like for example
the big forest fires that occurred in
the yellowstone national park
in the united states in 1988.
it devastated more than uh nearly 1
million hectares
in
with within about one full month it was
a terrible fire that was
devastating the most
important national park in the united
states and and the first one in the
world and really the icon of of nature
conservation
and
there was a big debate whether we should
put out these fires which were basically
natural because there was no one
igniting those fines it was a
thunderstorm that
that really was striking those
pine
landscapes and
you can really question yourself uh well
should we put out these files because
this is nature working
because these ecosystems have to
regenerate
every 200 years or
something like that okay and another
thing very different
very different is when you are in the
iberian peninsula in portugal for
example
where
93 of the fires are human caused
and where the
the
natural fire regime has been lost
at least
5 000 years ago
um
i don't think that this uh
national strategy of of cleaning up the
land
is sustainable
because it's not economically
sustainable
and it's not
ecologically sustainable
so there are other solutions that take
more time to to to reach
but they are more sustainable and they
give better results it came out a
program of landscape transformation
where
someone has dreamed one day that
[Music]
the the government could be the driver
of landscape transformation
at a country scale i don't believe in
that i read unfortunately i don't
but at the local scale i do because
there are several examples of that
there's many people like you
uh around the country there's many
people interested in restoring their
lands that don't want the the their
lands to be uh completely covered with
eucalyptus and cases they want something
else
they they just need an opportunity and
someone to guide them
and maybe some financial
[Music]
support as well because it costs money
to do that
and i'm so pessimistic about uh you gave
us hope
i gave you better at the local scale you
see but because i i don't see
i don't see how we we will change our
landscapes
i think we will have more and more
eucalyptus in the future and more and
more occasions and more and more forest
finders that's what i see at the
landscape scale
so you and some other people will be the
exceptions but unfortunately you will be
exceptions
so the interview with the professor was
cutted down the original one contains
much more information but it's also an
hour so we upload it in the research
module in case you want to see more
so here we are in the land it's 10
hectares there's a lot to burn it's a
hot summer day there are many fires
around us right now which is risky the
north of portugal is one of the most
risky areas of europe the land burned
down five years ago and professor says
it's likely again in like 10 15 years
risky there's a lot of eucalyptus forest
around us risky our own land is full of
exotic trees that love fire also risky
and climate changes around the corner
which is also risky
so you might wonder why would you live
on a place like that
it's a good question and i think we
actually see it as a challenge because
this problem is big here but it's
growing around the world and we cannot
just let all our force burn down we need
better solutions for this and we like to
be a place where we can test research
document this and share this with others
so they can replicate
so yeah that's going to be our long-term
process here for now we did a few
short-term fixes for this year
like installing some fire extinguishers
or bought a little water pump there in
case the electricity goes down we made a
fire evacuation plan
but in general this will be an ongoing
long topic we're going to research here
hopefully we find solutions in time
before this whole place burns down
let's see so yeah we're just gonna keep
on working first step is gonna take care
of the abandoned land then removing the
trees that catch fire then planting back
to right resilient fire trees
retaining the water here building lakes
a lot to be done we'll just continue
work and make sure to document it for
you guys
thanks for watching this special fire
episode and see you next time
you